hey guys how's it going welcome to the
egg Roulette challenge Shiloh will will
what if I am oh I'm waiting oh I'm
waiting with my sorry bad little bit
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here why hi i'm hen you put like
knowledge even keeping it in now welcome
to the egg Roulette challenge i'm here
with team edge and they're all gonna be
joining me on this awesome challenges
I've never done before but they have so
explain it it's eggs on your head
there's some hard-boiled eggs or some
raw eggs you don't want the raw eggs on
your head because it's wet and gooey wet
and gooey there's eight raw eggs in here
there's 12 right Oh ladies you know
who's hitting there I thought that's
what we talked about eight if the boots
ended but two for every site everyone
Thursday well killed and that Baker
girlfriend so once you get it by to ride
you're out you're not get it
oh that looks like that's a wrong one oh
how do you know I don't have you know
I'm smashing on you're having it out
[Applause]
laughs when they're all oh no you're
going next just on you oh you don't like
that you know he cheated go keep nice
I'm gonna get egg to ball oh man oh
you're saving dude Thank You Man three
two one
oh lucky right don't you can't look I
wasn't can I eat it yeah no wait oh it's
just where's the previous I mean I
didn't cook them for eating oh look at
all my I'm so glad God hasn't got a need
your good thing is this guy I do do is
boil some here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
they're not good yeah
now comes a loser agree so we all have
one in violin that's like a feed but
this a softy this boy is fine it's
catching
it's got you good go go roll if it is a
road in it stop oh you saw which one
you're old yeah exactly the one that I
touched when you ran the forehead ah
right on the forehead go buy the honors
no Martin you look beautiful honey the
owners I know Lori did you be enough
yeah
oh come on yeah I'm not gonna do it do
it yourself
you think maybe yeah yeah you did today
fredward put up a meet later flippin
Jeff red wins yeah a big one you got me
thanks me are you all came-- I'll give
you a [ __ ] later me
ha ha thanks man alright so alive
alright so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see another
challenge we're gonna be doing the soda
Roulette challenge something similar to
this
over on team edges channel so check it
out in the description below thanks guys
for joining me
although we'll see you the next one Oh
bye bye oh alright so next stop